it's 4:00 a.m. in the morning I'm waking
up in a Boston hotel room and can only
think of one thing tooth pain one of my
ceramic inlays fell off the evening
before five hours later I'm sitting in a
dentist's chair but instead of having a
repair of my inlay so that I can get rid
of my pain the dentist pitches me on the
advantages of a titanium implant surgery
ever heard of that it essentially means
to replace a damaged tooth by an
artificial one that is screwed into your
jaw estimated costs for the implant
surgery may add up to ten thousand US
dollars replacing this room in lahat
before would come at 800 US dollars was
it my health all the money that could be
earned with me that was the biggest
concern for my dentist as it turned out
my experience was in an isolated case a
study by an US national newspaper
estimated that in the United States up
to 30% of all surgical procedures
including Stan and pacemaker
implantation hip replacements and uterus
removals were conducted although other
non-surgical treatment options had not
been fully exploited by the physician in
charge isn't that figure shocking
numbers may be slightly different in
other countries but what it means is
that if you go to a doctor in the US you
have a not insignificant chance to the
subject of a surgical intervention
without being immediately for it why is
this why are some practitioners
incentivized to run such unnecessary
procedures well perhaps it is because
health care systems itself incentivized
in a non ideal way towards applying or
not applying certain procedures or
treatments
as most healthcare systems reimburse
practitioners in a fee-for-service based
fashion on the number and kind of
treatments performed it may be this
economic incentive that tempts some
practitioners to rather perform high
profit surgical treatments instead of
exploring other treatment options
although certain countries started to
implement performance based
reimbursement anchored on quality and
efficacy matrix overall there's very
little in today's healthcare systems
architecture to incentivize
practitioners broadly to actively
prevent the perience of a disease in the
first place and to limit the procedures
applied to a patient to the most
effective options so how do we fix this
what it may take is a fundamental
redesign of our healthcare systems
architecture a complete rethinking of
the incentive structure what we may need
is a healthcare system that reimburses
practitioners for keeping their
customers healthy instead of almost only
paying for services once people are
already sick what who may need is a
transformation from today's system that
largely cares for the sick to a system
that cares for the healthy to change our
current sick care approach into a true
health care approach it is a paradigm
shift from treating people once they
have become sick to preserving the
health of a healthy before they get sick
this shift may move the focus of all
those involved from doctors to hospitals
to pharmaceutical and medical companies
on the product that this industry
ultimately sells health imagine the
following what if we redesign our health
care system into one that does not
reimburse practitioners for the actual
procedures performed on a patient but
rather reimburse doctors hospitals
pharmaceutical and medical companies for
every day a single individual is kept
healthy and doesn't develop the disease
in practical terms we could for example
use public money to pay a health fee to
an insurance company for every day a
single individual is kept healthy and
doesn't develop a disease or doesn't
require any other form of acute medical
intervention if the individual becomes
sick the insurance company will not
receive any further monetary
compensation for the medical
interventions required to treat the
disease of that individual but they
would be obliged to pay for every
evidence-based treatment option to
return the customer back to health
once the customer is healthy again
the health fee for that individual will
be paid again in effect all players in
the system are now responsible for
keeping their customers healthy and
they're incentivized to avoid any
unnecessary medical interventions by
simply reducing the number of people
that eventually becomes sick the more
healthy people there are the less the
cost to treat the sick will be and the
higher the economic benefit for all
parties being involved in keeping these
individuals healthy is this change of
the incentive structure shifts now the
attention of the complete health care
system away from providing isolated and
singular treatment options towards an
holistic view of what is useful for an
individual to stay healthy and live long
now to effectively preserve health
people will need to be willing to share
their health data on a constant basis so
that the health care system understands
early enough if any assistance with
regard to the health is needed physical
examination monitoring of lifetime
health data as well as genetic
sequencing cardio metabolic profiling
and imaging based technologies will
allow customers to make together with
health coaches and general practitioners
optimal and science guided decisions for
the diet the medication and the physical
activity to diminish the uniqprobe
to fall sick of an identified individual
high-risk disease artificial
intelligence based data analysis and the
miniaturization of sensor technologies
are already starting to make monitoring
of the individual health status possible
measuring carry metabolic parameters by
devices like this or the detection of
circulating tumor DNA in your
bloodstream early on after cancer
disease onset are only two examples for
such monitoring technologies take cancer
one of the biggest problems in certain
oncological diseases is that a large
number of patients is diagnosed too late
to allow them to be cured although the
drugs and treatments that could
potentially have cured them are already
existing today if the disease had only
been detected earlier new technologies
allow now based on a few milliliters of
Bloods to detect the presence of
circulating tumor DNA and thus the
presence of cancer early on in a really
convenient manner the impact that this
early-stage detection can have may be
dramatic the five-year survival rate for
non small cell lung cancer when
diagnosed at stage one which is early is
49% the same when diagnosis stage 4
which is late is below 1% being
potentially able to prevent a large
number of deaths by something as simple
as a blood test for circulating tumor
DNA could make certain cancer types a
manageable disease as these onset can be
detected earlier and positive treatment
outcomes can likely be increased in 2012
50% of all Americans had a single
chronic disease residing an 86% of the 3
trillion dollar US healthcare budget
being spent for treating such chronic
diseases 86%
if new technologies allow now to reduce
this 86% why have healthcare systems not
reacted and changed already well a
redesign of what today is a sick care
system into a true health care system
that focuses on prevention and
behavioral changes requires every actor
in the system to change it requires the
political willingness to shift budgets
and policies towards prevention and
health education to design a new set of
financial and non-financial incentives
it requires creating a regulatory
framework for the gathering using and
sharing of personal health data that at
the same time stringent and sensible it
needs doctors hospitals insurance
pharmaceutical and medical companies to
reframe their approach and most
important it can't happen without the
willingness and motivation of
individuals to change their lifestyle in
a sustained way to prioritize staying
healthy in addition to opening up for
sharing their health data on a constant
basis this change may not come overnight
but by refocusing the incentives within
the healthcare industry today to
actively keep people healthy we may not
only be able to prevent more diseases in
the first place
but we may also be able to detect onset
of certain preventable diseases earlier
than we do today
which will lead to longer and healthier
lives for more people most of the
technologies that we need to initiate
that change are already existing today
but this is not a technology question it
is primarily a question of vision and
will thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]